the Joe Rogan experience you know the
guys when I rocked up to that community
super friendly really nice nice yeah
did you didn't speak though I didn't
speak their language you know one funny
story actually in the outside mountains
it was a Kazakh family so I'd always try
to eat and rest up with him where I
could so Kazakh family in their sort of
hot in middle of the Altai rocked up 45
minutes inside sippin on there I try
that tea eat in whatever they they gave
me and towards the end I was like wow
it's been 40 45 minutes I need to make a
move now and just as I was about to say
that I looked at the guy the man at the
heart it was a man in it and his wife a
girl he was looking at me very weird you
know I slightly squinted slightly close
like he's thinking of something you know
he looks over to his wife was girlfriend
then he looks back to me back at his
wife and then all of a sudden right
there and then in hand gestures me
offered me his wife whoa right there I
thought that sort of ancient because to
do this yeah he put it to the bed an
important it wasn't it I didn't know
what to do you know whoa you know no
that's it she's yours now bro we just it
was awkward silence for about 10 15 set
we'll exchange her look she was looking
at me I was looking I just put on a fake
laugh a couple of seconds later he
laughed with me and I made a swift exit
she continued breastfeeding a child so
she's breastfeeding Wow yeah why don't
you take a piece yeah whoa no is it one
of those things that this actually
happened or will I leave and they're
having a big joke right now and they're
laughing away the fact that you know you
just never know do you
I'm gonna guess if they live in tents in
the middle of nowhere and there's five
tents and takes forever to get there
those people are probably freaks
probably doing some weird freak [ __ ]
they probably have no attachment
whatsoever to sexuality
well maybe it's like here don't you like
to be really hospital I got super
hospitable you know but you do hear old
school exploration I've heared it before
but I didn't think in this generation
this day and age that still be going on
they probably live in like old school
Mongolians did yeah a little wild
sexually right from the far west so that
was a
like family so they would have come over
the border which is like mountain you
got the outside mountains separate so
this was in Kazakhstan this was West
Mongolia worst one but there's a heavy
population of cuz they're the ones that
actually hunt you know the Eagles right
in there the eagle perched on that
handli some foxes well how different
they look there there look like the
Kazakh is more of an area that's closer
to what
so kazakh has right on the on the border
so you've got Mongolia sandwiched
between Russia up north China down south
is just the name hazard yeah directly on
the west
you've got Kazakhstan okay but yeah
another I think that's the
second-largest line where a first
largest landlocked country in the world
Mongolia is the second largest
landlocked country in the world do
you're walking through this yes thanks
tur and that was my first trip there as
well so I didn't have the money to do a
recce like I did with China and
Madagascar I'd never been to the country
I rock it with her with the trailer when
you show up at Psalm 110 do you offer
some of them something for food like how
do you how do you worked that out I had
a piece of paper translated it described
who I was what I was doing why I'm here
and you're hoping they can read yeah
that's it hoping and some you write some
some couldn't but again you know you see
a guy looking at a messing you know big
beard down looking in pain looking
hungry looking skinny you pretty much
know shower you need shelter food water
so they did every time and they were
they were socially howling are people
being nice to you that's amazing yeah
and that's all I've ever done you know I
just a human rate I love it I love
people they're just so so friendly so
hospitable even the UK cyclin the UK is
when I was 20 I was raising funds for
the NSPCC it was illegal sometimes to
camp in a city so go on knocking so on
the door knock knock do you mind if I
set up my my tent in your front garden
all by Gordon please why I only had the
door son Tommy once it was an old guy
probably fell friend he just talked to
me slow she went back inside okay Archie
Bunker yeah but some families yeah they
were they were fine and that's amazing
that you that but did you have any funds
like could you give them money for food
if they were
willing to give it to you for free yeah
what did I say so I took paper and pens
for education purposes they love if you
can give their their child like paper
pens the child's will just be there kids
would just be playing with that you know
so you have a like a barter thing going
on yeah almost but sometimes they just
wouldn't accept it
they just plainly simply like no I had
that a lot in China as well so but you
didn't have any money I did I have cut
yeah I had cash with me but you never
offered anybody any money for food
ah no did that no yeah no maybe I did
maybe I did yeah but they were just
again they wouldn't accept it Wow
especially if I was sleeping the night I
would a hundred percent I take it no be
like no no it's tougher down my trailer
they you know yeah yeah and then I
learned that was it that I learned that
it was offensive to offer them money
because you're in their environment and
they know for themselves if they see I
had a guy won't run run me down on a
horse back from the distance coming at
me at speed and it was all just to give
me a bottle to take away with with tea
inside was I try again trying to offer
you came a distance I've been watching
you for ten minutes coming from a
distance from a distance little girl I
just to give me hot water tea so yes I
learned that was offensive to give the
money it's almost saying I'm better than
you I have money you don't but they're
rich in life they've gone and the
livestock the products they want to be
given and you're in there harsh
environment so I was like wow that's a
school so that's why stuck to the paper
and pens wow that's what a life-changing
experience that must have been yeah
that's sitting through a place where you
don't know any language at all meeting
these people and having them take you in
and feed you yeah yeah
I always incredible it renew your faith
in people at all what's that did it
renew your faith in people it did you
know I would say enhanced yet everywhere
eyes everywhere all over the different
countries and the troubles that I've
done that people have just been
absolutely amazing and I'm always trying
to give back in return sometimes they'll
take you which makes me happy sometimes
they're just not interested and they're
like no don't money order in China there
was one that the game loads of food they
gave me accommodation they then gave me
breakfast they gave me three days
worth of food to take away with me along
the Yangtze and they just wouldn't
accept my money would accept anything
that I like no my you know or the best
incredible
[Applause]